daniel bernard bonjour vous êtes conseil
municipal de jouy en josas est déléguée
à la maison léon blum vont se trouve
justement dans la maison léon blum du
joueur jose à celle qu'il a occupé au
fond pendant les cinq dernières années
de sa vie de 45 à 50
qu'est ce qu'on trouve dans cette maison
alors d'abord bonjour oui je alors on
trouvera effectivement déjà tous les
objets tels les collections donc qui ont
été effectivement légué par son épouse
parce que effectivement léon blum décès
dans cette maison donc en mars 1950 mais
de fait nous avons pris la pleine
propriété de cette maison donc que en
1982 à la demande de deux alors vous
allez loin à la demande effectivement
dans deux jeunes hommes qui avaient
préparé donc effectivement c'est dire
cette succession
cette maison lui appartenant
c'était sa maison dont qu'elle avait
acquise en 1937 puisqu'elle est une
propriété qui était beaucoup plus vaste
que celle que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui qu'elle avait acquise qui
appartenait donc antérieurement à la
princesse murale en 1937 donc lors de
son on était donc c'est madame brochen
bas qu'à l'époque elle avait
effectivement 3,3 époux successives le
premier enry thorez en réel qu'elle y
avait quatre à six avocats arrivants
dont qui a migré aux états unis célèbre
avocat d'ailleurs mentor de badinter et
donc ensuite effectivement donc à
l'épousé donc pas un degré bien un
industriel créateur des magasins des en
mode au prix unique et puis elle avait
toujours effectivement des sentiments
donc avoué ou cacher je dirais pour
effectivement cet homme enfin les
embouts pour l'écrivain l'auteur le
critique d'art etc alors aux
maisons derrière vous par exemple les
bibliothèques l'heure c'est vrai que
dans l'esprit du public naturellement
léon blum c'est l'homme politique c'est
le le président du conseil pour du du
front populaire
mais c'est aussi un homme de lettres ses
terres il a écrit des poèmes il a été
surtout un grand critique littéraire et
théâtrale exactement donc c'est un
certain homme de l'aide d'abord pour
puisque fillon dès sa prime jeunesse de
16 17 ans il écrivait des poèmes nous
avons d'ailleurs une collection de
poèmes de l'urne une collection inédite
donc depuis 80 poèmes auteur de pièces
de théâtre critique un des meilleurs
critiques de stendhal donc dans cette
période qu'on appelait le blairisme bon
contributeurs donc à une revue le dirait
la revue blanche voilà écrit de très
nombreux ouvrages et donc alors on voit
derrière où là il y avait il ya quelques
livres qui sont souvent des livres
dédicacés exactement alors je reviens
écriture
la carrière politique une allemande de
l'anglais dès ma retraite a redit non
oui ça à l'âge de 47 ans aimerait donc
47 ans a effectué en ce sont les
circonstances qu'il convient peut-être
de rappeler c'est ça c'est à l'école
normale là où il rencontrait donc je
dirais donc incertain d'autres collègues
et puis surtout sous l' influence de
lucien herr qui était le public decker
dans quelle école normale donc le cier
qui a été à je dirais
engagé dans le combat dreyfusards pour
effectivement l affaire dreyfus
reconnaisse l'innocence effectivement du
capitaine dreyfus et ses lacets je
dirais c'est rend compte dans un milieu
intellectuel la blouse ou avec le
missionnaire rencontre jaurès mais non
il ya aussi henri torres d'ailleurs bon
et je dirais donc blum effectivement
rentre aussi dans les airs et danses est
dans cette sphère politico center
politique enfin qui était une sphère
militants de l'unir et qui concernait
d'abord et avant tout je dirais le
combat pour les deux sens du capitaine
dreyfus oui c'est ça qui était le moteur
de son côté moteur pour l affaire
dreyfus des bars donc à la fin du
deuxième elle se termine donc début du
xxème et léon blum d'ailleurs ne prendra
sa carte alain sefyu qu'en 1905
est d'ailleurs après il a pris une carte
je dirais mais sans avoir une activité
politique non il était conseil d'état on
a été longtemps alors c'est ça qu'il
faut effectivement cité c'est que il a
aussi une intérieure je dirais john
idriss nos avocats une brillante
carrière plus de 25 ans donc au conseil
d'état reçue au concours bien sûr
auditeurs de deuxième classe 1re classe
m de retraite commissaire du
gouvernement et donc effectivement donc
toute cette période effectivement de de
l'homme de l'aide du juriste est
relativement méconnu effectivement du
contenu rich et nous souhaitons
effectivement nous dans cette maison je
dirais rire à remettre au boulot mais
devait y être multiples c'est un homme
aux multiples facettes plaît à leur gré
donc à qui on doit beaucoup car ce
combat politique après je dirais donc je
parle sur ses différents mandats de
parlementaire donc élu député de paris
battue ensuite ensuite député de
narbonne neurones même selon et puis
l'avènement bien évidemment de 7,2 ce
que tout le grand public fait le front
populaire c'est le front populaire donc
cette alliance effectivement entre le
parti socialiste le parti communiste et
les radicaux de gauche est bien humain
donc la remporte les élections donc
mai 1936 et ce gouvernement de front
populaire qui effectivement on va
promouvoir je dirais bien sûr des
revendications sociales que tout le
monde connaît les 40 heures les
conventions collectives mais pas
seulement je dirais y compris le dire un
centre de dispositions dans le domaine
du nombre des arts des lettres enfin
acquis que certains oui et du sport le
sport langevin exactement il est temps
donc il ya de multiples facettes et on
peut effectivement dates et les
conquêtes du front populaire donc 1936
1937 il reviendra au gouvernement après
la guerre il reviendra après la guerre
effectivement en 1942 lors de son
internement il a il a pris fait et cause
je dirais pour le général de gaulle donc
est la même je dirais plus apporter
quelques conseils pour ne pas dire plus
je dirai au général de gaulle en ce qui
concerne effectivement je dirais un
petit peu là la nécessité effectivement
de de regrouper je dirai tout les toutes
lettres des forces résistantes donc la
france il s'est rallié donc au général
de gaulle et il a même conseillé puisque
en particulier
il a même fait valoir le général de
gaulle auprès de chercher des annuaires
qui ne qui ne voulaient pas reconnaître
forcément le général de gaulle les raye
compris après l'appel de 10 watts et
surtout il disait effectivement aux
américains surtout ne fait pas appel aux
hommes de vichy en afrique du nord et en
est à la suite effectivement de et de
gaulle lui rend d'ailleurs hommage pour
dénoncer mémoire dans le tome 1 de ces
noirs et on peut effectivement ajouté
que
de gaulle lui a proposé hier un poste de
ministre d'état dès sa libération dès
son retour de phuket ballons qu'il a
refusé il était fatigué donc voilà il y
aura un gouvernement qui reviendra au
gouvernement je dirais un volant
transitoire qui n'arriveraient six
semaines bon je dirais de le temps que
les différentes arrangement politique se
fasse voilà alors ils habitaient déjà
alors ça c'est alors qu'est ce qui
faisait ici alors qu'est ce qu'ils
faisaient ici alors bon une nouvelle
grille quand même non alors il a
beaucoup écrit alors déjà il écrivait
tous les jours
je dirais donc des hittites haut pour le
populaire le populaire le dernier édito
dit l'ailier c'était la veille de sa
mort donc
en
1950 dans cette maison surtout il
écrivait il recevait recevait il
recevait beaucoup de monde d'ailleurs le
dirait la presse de l'époque et même les
plus anciens d'entre nous à jouy en
josas l'avait baptisé le pape ou le sage
de georges lot puisque effectivement il
y avait un défilé de voitures
automobiles à l'époque naissance 1,2145
950 17-16 fameuse traction j'ai été
breaké l'aigle il est consulté le sage
le sage de josas voilà pour à l'époque
c'était un peu les confidents politique
était un petit peu délicate et
laborieuse dans les témoignages des gens
qui ont pu peut-être le côtoyer il était
non le voyez à certains c'est un homme
qui était très très très abordable par
alors très abordable parce qu'aussi il
avait transcendé justement tous les
courants politiques avec une conviction
profonde qui était la sienne en tant que
socialiste bon mais je dirais il était
reconnu je dirais par par diverses
sensibilités et aussi bien je parle pas
de la période avant du front populaire
ou même avant avant 36 ou là il a été
victime d'une campagne louis haurie les
mythes affreuse antisémite bon ça
perdure est quand même un petit peu
le rap est donc c'était un sujet
d'ailleurs qui n'eut des animaux très
très dur il faudrait dire et comme c'est
ainsi un sujet d'actualité il faut donc
c'est un combat qu'il faut mener de
façon permanente cela étant donc en
cette qualité de sages ils recevaient
effectivement beaucoup de monde il
donnait des conseils le côté pour
répondre à votre question le côté
abordable le cas d'ailleurs le préciser
au passage on avait deux maisons de la
shoah par exemple ici et sinon il y
avait des enfants donc orphelin donc et
bien par exemple tous les dimanches il
invitait quelques enfants ici dans sa
maison avec jane fait direct pour leur
offrir un petit goûter je dirais en
accord alors passons maintenant à ce qui
va se passer dans cette maison parce que
la mairie de jouy en josas essayer de
faire vivre cette maison évidemment ça
coûte cher très cher effectivement donc
la culture ça coûte cher et ça rapporte
pas forcément je dirai tout de suite
c'est pas tout de suite donc c'est un
investissement intellectuel culturel et
dans le projet de la municipalité
effectivement donc c'est de faire
revivre cette maison de l'art vinifier
on a déjà réalisé une première phase
donc de travaux que c'était les travaux
disant pas
très précis de protection de son église
dont le clos et le couvert et le projet
de la municipalité actuelle donc ça
c'est la deuxième tranche évidemment
c'est de permettre effectivement donc un
accueil plus important des pays que je
dis bien des publics parce
qu'effectivement notre notre petit c'est
de faire venir un public jeune bien sûr
et pour ce faire nous avons besoin
effectivement donc de réaliser ensemble
de travaux de travaux d'aménagement
réalisés également une salle d'accueil
pour qu'on puisse effectivement
l'installer si bien les personnes les
seniors que que chez les jeunes
je dirais m de façon alors présenté la
maison
l'histoire de leur boulot pour leur
faire visiter une maison qui reste quand
même petit dans ses dimensions qui reste
dans son jus comment est une maison
d'habitation vol a été mise en vigueur
et qui est une des rares maisons je
dirais d'homme d'état ouais parce qu'il
ya très peu finalement et de faire
connaître effectivement donc tout ce que
je viens de vous citer enfin sur la vie
de l'an bonne depuis les engrais sa
naissance en 1072 jusqu'à sa mort en
1950 alors pratiquement alors d'abord le
11 juin il va se passer quelque chose
alors le 11 juin va se passer
effectivement une un événement seront
donc et on a effectivement fait en sorte
effectivement pour trouver les moyens de
financement donc de sensibiliser à ces
acteurs alors on a en a critiqué des
bailleurs de fonds publics le conseil
général le conseil régional
d'ile-de-france l'état bien sûr au
travers du ministère de la culture la
drac monuments historiques musées de
france donc tout sous tous ses
financeurs publics je dirais bon
effectivement ils ont des lignes mais
cela ne suffit pas je dirais d'autoriser
l'objectif de la municipalité est
financé la totalité des projets dont on
a fait appel au public donc on a décidé
effectivement de faire appel au public
et utiliser je dirais la loi aillagon
façon et senna dans culturels en
particulier
nous avons et nous le 11 juin pour
répondre précisément à votre question
langevin nous allons signer donc une
convention avec la fondation du
patrimoine qui relaie quelque sorte cet
appel aux dons et aux mécènes d'accord
donc les boîtes réguliers vont pouvoir
faire des dons alors les particuliers
vont devoir faire des dons mais compte
tenu aussi des enjeux en recherchant
effectivement des mécènes comme usé mais
seulement comme cela s'est fait par
exemple à la maison zola donc
voilà dans sa tombe je viens
d'opérations de ce type et donc nous
allons donc dans un premier temps donc
le 11 juin à 11 heures à l'école hec
donc deux jours aux as donc présenté le
projet de la municipalité avec son maire
donc jacques bélier et bien qu'un
certain nombre d'intervenants présentés
figurent le projet scientifique le
projet scénographique enfin donc donner
les informations utiles pour
qu'effectivement les donateurs et les
mécènes sache très bien le dire est
qu'elle est la nature et l'objectif de
ce projet alors il ya un site sur lequel
on peut alors il ya ainsi plus haut
niveau qui est celui de la fondation de
france alors je le donne c'est c'est ww
point fondation tirer patrimoine point
org
slash dont tirait léon blum il trouvera
tous les soleils sur le site façon de la
fondation de france vous allez retrouver
tout de suite les informations active et
puis bien évidemment nous avons une
chargée de mission je dirais donc à la
mairie de change là sur la personne de
madame boyer est tout à fait à même
effectivement de répondre aux donateurs
potentiels aux mécènes et bien
évidemment nous les attendons le dire
est que les bras ouverts merci beaucoup
aux douaniers leur mère leur cible